zielinski went to Washington at a time
when his people are suffering I mean
Russian drones made another brutal
attack on the capital city of Kiev
Monday from the beginning soldiers and
civilians have been under Russian attack
our Ian Lee is in Kiev this morning Ian
good morning I want to ask you what are
people there saying about zielinski's
trip here
good morning David people here were
happy to see President zielinski travel
to the United States ukrainians are
hoping for more military as well as
humanitarian Aid especially in bucha a
city now known for Russian atrocities
the Russians may have fled bucha but
their presence still haunts the town
Janetta butenko has no water no
electricity and no family
she says the Russians took everything
from her including her sense of humor
the 83 year old adopted an abandoned dog
named Charlie zanetta melt snow and ice
for them to drink while foodaid keeps
them alive What would life be like
without this kind of assistance
there's no way I would survive she tells
me Rabbi Rafael Rutman provides this
life-saving Aid the war is affecting
everyone and we give everybody else
to thousands of people from all
religions rely on his Organization for
food and water these people that are
desperate just to be able to survive
they have no water they have no
electricity they have no Heating
Solinski went to Washington to get his
country the tools to win the fight
ukrainians back home are optimistic
about his trip it's uh and evidence that
we are part of the western free world
that we are welcome well many here see
they're suffering as a small price to
pay to beat the Russians 84 year old
genya mataritska tells me the soldiers
and the trenches have it worse she may
be the only Jewish person in her
building but she makes sure Rabbi
rutman's Aid goes to everyone
her neighbors hugged and kissed her but
she said this is not from me it's from
the Jewish Community because of this war
no matter your religion everyone is
Ukrainian
just to highlight how desperate the
situation is for many people it's
currently Hanukkah we've seen how the
candles provided by Rabbi Rutman are
doubling as a source of heat to cook
food Nate
source of heat and hope of course Inland
Ukraine thank you